Promoters are typically found in front of
the transcription initiation site. Though, they don't
always have to be. This serves an obvious purpose as a landing platform for all
the proteins that come together to initiate
transcription at this spot here. Remember, in the
cellular world proteins make the world go
round. Now there's a generic class of proteins
referred to as transcription factors. Which are just proteins
that bind DNA and regulate the initiation of transcription.
As you can imagine, many of these proteins, many
of these transcription factors, essentially bind in this promoter region.
And physically regulate the initiation of transcription via chemistry.
Now, not only can these proteins interact with the
DNA of the promoter region. But they interact with
each other as well. You can sort of see that
depicted here. They're all bound to one another.
And through these many interactions, they're able to
facilitate the overall outcome for this particular gene.
Now, although this is ultimately chemistry. We become pretty
good at representing chemistry with our letter symbols.
Let's imagine that one of the transcription factors
up here, one of these proteins, is actually
binding to a very specific sequence here in the
DNA. TGACGTCA. Let's just say there was a change in this sequence here so that
this G is missing, there's a small deletion, let's say. And now the sequence
reads TGAC-TCA. Do you think this change
in the DNA sequence at a promoter region
would result in the transcription factor binding
more tightly, less tightly, or not at all?